[Music]
the world has approximately seven point
seven billion people on it until now
half of the world's population has been
snapped out of existence instantly if
you happen to be one of the three point
eight billion people left having
survived this mass wipe out what would
happen to you would you be able to
survive how would society function after
such a decimation and could this end up
being a good thing for Humanity this is
what if and here's what would happen if
half the world's population suddenly
disappeared with 50% of the population
disappearing in the blink of an eye
there would be mass chaos one thing
that's bound to happen plane crashes
there are approximately 10,000 planes in
the sky at any given moment carrying
over 1 million people some of the people
disappearing in this mass elimination
are bound to be pilots flying planes
this would be a problem for people on
the ground as well as for those in the
sky since it would be completely
unpredictable where these unmanned
planes would crash there would be
hundreds of thousands of car pileup sand
train crashes you wouldn't want to be
undergoing surgery at the time imagine
lying on the operating table in the
middle of a procedure when all of a
sudden the surgeon disappears if you
were to survive all the chaos and
destruction that would follow this mass
vanishing it wouldn't be such a joyous
moment half of your family and half of
your friends would be gone sorry about
that
however once you get over the crushing
and confusing loss of your loved ones
this could be a good thing but not right
away at first civilization would have to
deal with losing people who held
essential jobs around the world the
number of world leaders police officers
firefighters and power grid workers
would all have taken a massive hit
making their jobs difficult or
impossible to complete and in turn
affecting the people who remained on
earth massive blackouts would occur
and people would generally be less safe
for a short time our food supply would
suffer severely with essential products
being shipped from all around the world
there's less of a possibility of people
getting what they need the number of
people who grow or make food sell it and
ship it would be significantly reduced
but what happens after the dust settles
and civilization is able to adjust to
this new world well believe it or not
humanity has already dealt with
something very similar to this event
known as the Black Death in the mid
1300s Europe was met with a bacterial
infection that wiped out 25 million
people equal to about half of the
continents population at the time
although the world was met with tons of
death and despair
there were also benefits that resulted
from this event during a time when food
supplies were scarce food became more
plentiful due to there being fewer
mouths to feed
the same could be applied to the world
today approximately 36 million people
die each year from hunger with 50% fewer
people to feed and the world having the
same amount of food as it did before the
bellies of the world would be much more
full and the benefits wouldn't stop
there another thing that happened during
the Black Death that would happen in our
scenario you'd be a lot richer assuming
the world economy stabilizes after this
huge event you'd be able to charge a lot
more for your skills you could end up
being the only person in your town who
knows how to repair a car or perform
surgery or even cook a decent meal with
fewer people your skills would be in
higher demand resulting in you earning
more money and speaking of money
wherever you choose to live would be
much cheaper since there'd be so many
more available homes you'd no longer be
spending your entire paycheck on rent
and what about all the things in the
world that aren't human what would
happen with them well the earth would
slowly begin to heal itself from climate
change fewer people means less pollution
and less harm to the environment with
50% less people on earth there's a good
chance we'd be able to live comfortably
on her
the next hundred years unlike what will
happen if we keep up our current
population size once you forget about
the horrible mass elimination that
occurred this world sounds pretty good
you'd be richer and fatter and the earth
would be healthier unfortunately in a
couple of centuries or so we most likely
be back to where we started but even if
that happens the world may still end up
surviving the core problem is not how
many of us there are but how we use the
planet and share its resources in theory
we could have 14 billion people and
still have a thriving planet as long as
we use our resources correctly now what
would happen if this were to actually
happened and the world's population
suddenly doubled well that sounds like a
story for another what if